pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est par un pèlerinage à douaumont que
le général de gaulle a voulu commencer
son voyage en lorraine le 13e qu'il
effectue à travers la france du hautmont
ces quatre cent mille morts et le temps
qui a passé reste sans effet sur un
pareil ici
[Musique]
de verdun ce devait être durant quatre
jours la visite à toute la lorraine à
bar-le-duc à epinal comme tout au long
de ce voyage la chaleur de l'accueil
fait au chef de l'état l'a disputé à la
chaleur tout coup
20 soit en cinq jours le général de
gaulle a pris la parole vingt fois il a
traité du problème algérien et comme à
nancy
il a évoqué les rapports d'associations
qui comporte la compréhension des
communautés à l'intérieur et l'appui de
la france à metz
avant de serrer les mains tendues le
général de gaulle avait encore affirmé
l'association est aujourd'hui la
solution du bon sens au cap canaveral
l'armée de l'air américaine en lançant
au moyen d'une seule fusée trois
satellites d'un coût a réussi un exploit
exceptionnel
l'ensemble pèse 500 tonnes et mesure 24
mai
au moment où la vitesse orbitale
atteignait 26 mille kilomètres
l'explosion a été déclenchée et les
trois lunes artificielles devaient se
séparer pour se placer sur une orbite à
une altitude d'environ 9 125 kg mais aux
dernières nouvelles
deux d'entre elles sont restées
solidaires le premier satellite est
destiné à mesurer les rayons x du soleil
le deuxième satellite est chargée de
mesurer les radiations qui entoure le
globe terrestre
le troisième satellite alimentée par une
batterie nucléaire est destiné à l'étude
des télécommunications et naviguera
pendant une cinquantaine d'années
[Musique]
koweit et aujourd'hui le nom de nouveaux
points névralgiques du glock au moment
où il venait d'accéder à l'indépendance
l'ancien protectorat britannique s'est
vu l'objet des visées annexionnistes du
général kasem de la cette manifestation
de la foule venue proclamer la volonté
de l'émirat de demeurer indépendant
aussi l'appel de l'émir à l'aide
militaire britannique
quatrième producteur de pétrole du monde
koweit n'a pas fini de faire parler de
lui en face malgré la table ronde
les agriculteurs n'ont pas désarmé le
midi a tenu à son tour a expérimenté la
technique des barrages ce qui le soleil
aidant n'a pas toujours convaincu les
automobilistes et autres conducteurs de
camions de la correction du procédé et
manifestants n'en avait pas moins leurs
supporters et la ronde désormais
traditionnel détracteurs est allés bon
train dans la région de château renard
qui est le premier marché européen des
primeurs
on a compté près de cinq mille tracteurs
au pont de beaune ya sur la durance
face à ces déploiements il ne restait
aux touristes que d'essayer la marche
arrière ou la patience et de rêver avec
nostalgie à la trêve prônée par les
dirigeants des fédérations agricoles
le mécontentement paysans persiste la
route des vacances demeurent coupées
[Rires]
à flins les raisons de mécontentement
était différente les ouvriers ont trouvé
porte close
la régie renault pour réagir contre la
grève perlée avait décidé un lock out
qui devait d'ailleurs ne durer qu'une
journée
après quelques hésitations les ouvriers
devaient pourtant finir par adopter la
technique paysanne faute de tracteurs
ils ont quand même barré la route en
s'asseyant dessus
[Musique]
l'époque des vacances c'est aussi celle
qui est choisie pour effectuer les
travaux les plus importants de la voirie
parisienne
de sorte que le pari d'été apparaît
comme un vaste chantier dans ce paris là
le tourisme devient une petite aventure
qui demande autant de sang froid que de
persévérance
[Musique]
singulier paris que celui ci avec ces
trous ces débris qui brûle et ses
barrières
ah ah
l'hôtel de sens l'un des plus
remarquables du marais est ainsi devenu
pratiquement inaccessible à moins d'être
un gymnaste distinguer
le génie de la bastille semble trôner
sur un chantier de construction
et les touristes pourront toujours
s'étonner de l'acharnement qu'ont semble
avoir mis à multiplier les pièges sous
leurs pas oui un bien curieux paris
[Applaudissements]
une tradition des saintes veut que la
saison parisienne trouve son apothéose à
versailles avec le bal des débutantes
elle était cette année près de 200
jeunes filles du monde françaises et
étrangères qui pour leurs 18 ans ont eu
l'honneur de faire la révérence devant
la princesse napoléon
[Musique]
cascades de robes lumineuses signé des
grands noms de la haute couture etc l'un
des bijoux sourire une brillante entrée
dans le monde qui eut aussi le mérite de
faire apprécier ces jeunes filles bien
née les plaisirs de la danse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
35 degrés à l'ombre c'est une
température de vacances aussi la vie à
paris s'était notablement engourdi pour
prendre un rythme estival à l'heure du
premier rush vers les plages et la
montagne
pendant ce temps les gars étaient
littéralement assiégé 200000 parisien
ils sont partis en trois jours
à l'occasion de ces départs le train
auto couchette s'est intégré un peu plus
à la tradition des vacances la sncf a
mis en service sur la ligne paris
biarritz un nouveau train d'automobiles
accompagné qui prend en charge les
véhicules en même temps que les
voyageurs une solution originale sans
aucun doute qui permet tout en gardant
pour ainsi dire sa voiture sous la main
d'oublier les soucis de là
[Musique]
dans le même temps le chemin de la côte
d'azur s'est raccourcie par l'ouverture
dans cette cavité de l'autoroute estérel
côte d'azur qui est la première
autoroute française à péage il convient
de noter que sa construction qui a duré
cinq ans a coûté 22 milliards d'anciens
francs
désormais grâce à ses 63 km d'autoroute
on n'est pas pour ce parcours moitié
moins de temps gain appréciable pour les
vacanciers pressé d'arriver à la mer et
ils le sont toujours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
record battu pas celui du circuit b
celui des températures le thermomètre a
failli ne pas résister à la chaleur
les pilotes non plus et les voitures
encore moins celle qu'on l'attendait à
l'arrivée les ferrari du sinn se sont
rapidement des pouilles menés après un
départ tambour battant et finalement
c'est tout de même une ferrari celle de
l'italia baguette ti qui anime les
preuves
pourtant pas getty les blacks pour faire
de la figuration intelligente en
quelques tours de circuit
il devient une vedette une vedette qui
doit se battre jusqu'au dernier tour
avec les deux porsche de bonnier et de
l'américain coeur né pendant des
kilomètres et des kilomètres c'est un
chassé-croisé incessant entre les trois
voitures à près de 200 à leur dernier
tour bonnier est out plus que deux
bolides pour la première place une
première place qui se joue au sprint
comme dans une course cycliste
mais à deux cent soixante dix à leurs
bagues et ya gagné ses galons de grand
pilote
[Musique]